microwave think of all the lives I
changed we was robbing put that mask on
I was Bane
then this said I just came I
dropped her off and blew the horn like a
Vikings game don't ever think me and
these guys the same I really stood
outside and slain for everything that I
obtained hey
and you can put that to the fire flame
so crack I had to find the lane music
now it's time to change yeah look I
really had them grams before you had a
grand and that exotic's fun to smoke but
the Platt's a Wham and with the hassle
Fam I'm smoking kush and Castle bam
Philly block is jumping right looks
like a traffic jam good work no longer
hard to find they wrapped around the
block up early morning like the
Starbucks line y'all ain't got the
harder lines y'all Master the art of
line and I could see it bleeds through
every time you talk you trying they
booked my man buying Sudafed he beat the
case gave it back now he's in court
trying to sue the feds they couldn't
find a Seattle cause dude was dead bad
decisions